despite a nothing burger New York Times
report Democrats keep doubling down on
Brett Kavanaugh Elizabeth Warren flexes
her muscles and debate breaks out among
Republicans over Iran i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
you know our goal each and every day
here at the ben shapiro show is to bring
you the news and also to trend on
twitter so today well yesterday was a
great day we're gonna see if we can
match that today we're gonna try and
trend on twitter nearly every day
because hell as my old mentor andrew
breitbart used to say whatever doesn't
kill me just makes me more famous but in
any case in any case we'll begin with
the still news of the day and that is
this ridiculous New York Times supposed
bombshell on Brett Kavanaugh so you'll
recall from yesterday's famous show that
the New York Times had this report it
was in the news analysis section it was
not in the news section because it
wasn't actually news it was in the news
analysis section so they could pretend
that it was quasi news and it was this
excerpt from a book called the education
of Brett Kavanaugh and the new bombshell
report is that some dude who worked in
Washington nonprofit that's all we knew
about him that this person says that he
had once witnessed-- another dude pushed
Brett Cavanaugh's penis into the hand of
a woman who was sitting there this was
the story
I'm not laughing because that would be
funny if it happened I'm laughing
because literally every aspect of the
story is ridiculous up to and including
the fact that as it turns out the book
itself reports that the alleged victim
in this case doesn't remember any of
this she was remember any of this but
the New York Times didn't actually
report originally that she didn't
remember any of this in fact the
original report said nothing about the
alleged victim making it appear as
though there was a substantiating and
corroborated piece of evidence about
Brett Kavanaugh exposing himself to
unapprove in women in an act of sexual
assault as it turns out that was a bunch
of crap and the New York Times had to
issue a correction in which they
acknowledged that yes indeed the alleged
victim says that she doesn't recall any
such event and amazingly enough this
morning the authors of the book at issue
Robyn Pogue Urban and Kate Kelly and
they were appearing on television and
they explicitly state they explicitly
point out that the New York Times
original draft did include the line
where it said that the alleged victim
had no memory of the incident and that
the seller editors engaging in
unbelievable levels of journalism remove
that line so the original report
now it's not just that they missed the
line or that it wasn't there in the
first place they had a line in there
saying the alleged victim in this case
doesn't remember the incident won't be
interviewed any of that that was in the
original piece and the New York Times
editors in all of their wisdom and glory
decided to remove that from the piece
here Robyn Pogue urban and K Kelly who
actually write for the New York Times
talking about this somewhere in the
editing process those words were yeah I
mean I think what happened actually was
that you know we had her name and you
know The Times doesn't usually include
the name of ricktum and so I think in
this case the editors felt like maybe it
was probably better to remove it and in
removing her name they removed the other
reference to the fact that she didn't
remember so the way in your draft for
the times you used basically the exact
words ever in the book that I
deliberately left off the name because
that passage begins with the name and so
in their removal of the name they ended
up removing what follows yes Oh oops
oops we took out the only relevant
portion of the story which is that the
alleged victim doesn't remember this
story ever happening okay so how nothing
burger was this story here's how nothing
burger this story was Vanity Fair is
reporting this morning quote why did the
Cavanaugh excerpt end up in the review
in the New York Times review books
people familiar with how things went
down told me that Kelly and pogrom an
initially pitched their scoop to the
news side but the top editors ultimately
felt there wasn't enough juice to
warrant a story there let alone a big
page one treatment instead PO gourbin
and Kelly were told they could pitch the
review which is entirely independent of
the news department I asked for
clarification as to what about the story
wasn't news pages worthy but the times
declined to comment as did Kelly and
pogrom in a Times spokesperson did
however point out it's not unusual for
opinion or sunday review pieces to break
news okay the real answer is because
there was no news there there's no news
there I'm sorry an allegation by a third
party who will not go on record when
talking with you and also who's in which
the alleged victim says that she has no
memory of the incident that's not news
that's just called somebody saying a
thing that's not in and of itself news
now here's the funny part there was an
actual piece of news in the education of
Brett Kavanaugh a pretty
piece of news as it turns out what was
this piece of news well Jen Crawford of
CBS reported it okay the actual piece of
news is that Blasi for Christine Blasi
Ford who was the original big-name
accuser against Brett Cavanaugh's
professor out in California who
suggested the back when he was 17 years
old he held her down on a bed while
laughing and tried to rape her and that
was emblazoned in her memory and all of
this well she had suggested that there
is a woman named Leland Keyser with whom
she was friends and that her friend was
at the party
well according to Jen Crawford at CBS
Leland Kaiser says that in the book that
Christine Blasi Ford's story is not
believable and that Christine Blasi
Ford's allies pressured Leland Kaiser to
change her story now it seems to me that
this would be you know the definition of
actual news if it turns out that the
biggest news story in America the news
story that put Christine Blasi Ford on
the cover of national news magazines and
had her touted as a me to heroin if it
turns out that her close friend who was
supposed to be the person backing up her
story said the story is not number one
not believable and number two I was
pressured by Ford and her allies to lie
about it
isn't that a page one news story here at
CBS Evening News reporting this speaking
publicly for the first time to The Times
reporters Ford's close friend Leland
Kaiser who Ford said was at the party
said she didn't believe Ford's account
and that it just didn't make any sense
she also says she told the FBI that
four's allies pressured her to say
otherwise now all four people that Ford
identified as being at that high school
party in the summer of 1982 have now
said no such party occurred that's
unbelievable
how is that not the front page news good
for CBS for covering this but what in
the actual hell what the hell so we get
now a new renewed debate over
allegations with regard to Debra Ramirez
that were supposedly corroborated by a
completely separate incident
substantiated by a third party who says
that he saw a completely separate
incident Alec Debra Ramirez but about a
separate woman who denies that the
incidents occurred or that she remembers
it and that is front-page news that is
news
we have to cover on the front page oh my
god how could the Republicans not
investigate investigate what an
allegation by one dude that a thing
happened where the victim says it didn't
happen like what exactly is supposed to
be investigated there but you know what
we should definitely definitely not
report on at least not on the front page
of the New York Times is the allegation
in the same exact book in by the same
exact authors that the key allegation in
the Brett Kavanaugh saga in the first
place was doubted by the key witness
cited by the alleged victim Christine
Blasi Ford she she's the one who called
out Leland Kaiser and she's like yeah my
friend Lee Zink Leland can back this up
and Leland Kaiser was like nah sorry
this thing doesn't wash I remember
anything like this that make any sense
to me and by the way
Christine blaze afforded her friends
were pressuring me to lie about this
this is in the education of breka in the
same book in the same book
now that is newsworthy that should be on
page one of the New York Times but
instead that doesn't mean her Times is
all at all so Maggie Haberman over the
New York Times after Jan Crawford over
at CBS reported this is unbelievable
Maggie Haberman tweeted out yeah we have
the neuro Times knew that we knew that
right actually we reported that said
well did you report that and you know
the same bold headline banner fashion as
you reported this crap allegation by Max
tires who as it turns out we now have
details on and was a lawyer for Bill
Clinton during his impeachment in the
1990s we're now everyone connected with
these stories is super political
connected super politically connected
Molly Hemingway also reporting that one
of the reporters in this particular book
Pogue urban was a longtime roommate at
Yale with Kathy Charlton a woman
centrally involved in the anti Cavanaugh
efforts according to public statements
from her husband visit it's it's unreal
it's unreal none of this withstands a
moment's scrutiny not a moment's
scrutiny and yet somehow the story that
the media take away from this is that
Brett Kavanaugh needs to be impeached
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about making your
company better hiring can be difficult
it can be slow can be arduous kephale
Torre's CEO odilon Miska wits he needed
to hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company but he was having
trouble finding qualified applicants so
he switched over to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and then then
invites them to apply to your job so you
will get qualified candidates and get
them fast dylan posted his job on sip
recruiter said he was impressed by how
quickly he had great candidates apply he
also uses if Cooter's candidate rating
feature to filter his applicants so he
could focus on the most relevant ones
and that's how Dylan found his new
director of coffee in just a few days
with the results like that it's no
wonder that four out of five employers
who posted on sip recruiter can Equality
candidate within the very first day I
mean zip recruiter is fantastic every
day I look around the office and I think
who should I think about replacing with
zip recruiter today like for example
yesterday we have a makeup artist here
named Jess and just is just a wonderful
person I love Jess a lot she's terrific
but just decided to walk to the wrong
studio and then walk back to this studio
so by the time she got here she was like
an hour late and she was pouring sweat
from walking in New York's terrible
humidity and I thought to myself how
could I make her day better well
theoretically I could fire her and
replace her with zip recruiter I decided
not to do that in the end but zip
recruiters that come would have been the
resource that I would have used if I
decided to replace Jess with somebody
who knows directions go check out zip
recruiter right now zip recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at our web
address zip recruiters comm slash at
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash Dai ly WI re try em out for free
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
zipper queries indeed the smartest way
to hire so as I say there was an actual
piece of news in this book to education
to Brett Kavanaugh it was not reported
anywhere except on CB s like a day later
okay then there was a piece of crap news
and that was the max tire piece of news
and it was just nonsense
it was just a nonsense piece of news cuz
it wasn't news hey and that ends up
being the big story of the day yesterday
20 20 Democratic candidates coming out
and saying that Brett Kavanaugh should
be impeached over all of this in the
Federalist which got an advance copy of
the book reports quote the book offers
no evidence in support of the
allegations made by Christine Blasi Ford
but write the author's their gut
reaction was that her allegations rang
true which means nothing I'm sorry that
means nothing if I make an allegation
like oh well that rings true well that
sounds like evidence in court to me it
rings true so when you watch a detective
show and sometimes like I'm working off
a good instinct yeah well gut instincts
in the past have been
about pretty much everything apparently
their gut instinct was based on the fact
that Blasi Ford and Cavanaugh grew up in
the same rough area and she had once
dated one of his friends further Leland
Kaiser had gone out on a date maybe even
two dates they're not sure with a friend
of Cavanaugh's none of that means that
Ford was in fact assaulted by Cavanaugh
they right but it does mean she has a
baseline level of credibility as an
accuser what exactly is that supposed to
mean at the end of the book according to
Malley Hemingway the author said quote
we spoke multiple times to Leland Kaiser
who also said she didn't recall that
get-together or any others like it in
fact she challenged Ford's accuracy I
don't have any confidence in the story
hey Hemingway also has detailed the
pressure applied on Kaiser to get her to
back up for its tale so does the new
book it says that Ford's friends had
quote grown frustrated with Kaiser her
comments about the alleged Cavanagh
incident had been too limited some of
them felt and did not help their friends
case surely given what a close friend
Kaiser had been she could say more to
substantiate for its testimony and
general veracity even if she could not
corroborate Ford's more specific
memories except she was supposed to been
at the party so if she had gone out and
said you know I don't remember this but
Kristine I totally believe her how could
she say that having been at the same
party apparently Kaiser told the
author's quote I was told behind the
scenes that certain things could be
spread about me if I didn't comply how
is that not page one news who was saying
to an alleged witness of a sexual
assault that there would be rumors
spread about her if she didn't comply
with their wishes to test about testify
about something that she didn't know to
be true I mean that's a criminal act
folks if you're trying to suborn perjury
right if you pressure somebody to lie
and you threaten them to lie under oath
presumably if you try to blackmail them
forget about suborning perjury which
requires an actual judicial proceeding
if you try to blackmail somebody to do
something by threatening to release
information about them that is a crime
that is called black how is that not a
page-one story the new book also delves
into one bizarre aspect of Ford's claim
according to Joe Carroll over a Daily
wire how she got home after she abruptly
left the party as previously reported
injustice on trial
Kaiser continues to think about the
story in which she was supposed to have
played a part she has both logistical
and character-driven problems with it
focusing on one of the angles that many
women had trouble believing she says
quote it would be
possible for me to be the only girl at a
get-together were three guys have her
leave and then not figure out how she's
going to get home
the authors previously note that Blasi
Ford suggested that Kaiser might have
driven her home which they do not note
is a change from her claim she doesn't
know how she got home
Kaiser also reflects that the
get-togethers of their youth were not
like the one for described she says I
just really didn't have confidence in
the story I mean it's just it's unreal
it's unreal so there is a real story
here is the story that the media are
largely ignoring except for Jan Crawford
and CBS the New York Times instead
deciding to focus on a story that turns
out to be complete and sheer nonsense
it's truly amazing by the New York Times
by the way defended its coverage and the
way they defended their coverage is just
ridiculous so they they have a piece
today titled answers to reader questions
on our Brett Kavanaugh essay The Times
is deputy editorial page editor James
Dow answers questions about how they
handled the essay on the Supreme Court
justice and a third accusation of sexual
misconduct now I want you know how they
even pitch the supposed third aspect
with sexual misconduct so they say quote
the essay included a previously
unreported claim that friends pushed mr.
cavros penis into the hand of a female
Yale student during a dorm party with
drunken classmates during the author's
investigation they learned that a
classmate max tyre witnessed the event
and later reported it to Senators into
the FBI
the authors corroborated his story with
to government officials who said they
found it credible based on that
corroboration
we felt mentioning the claim as one part
of a broader essay was warranted so even
that last part we you know as part of a
broader as I mentioned it suggests that
there's no substantiation and that this
is super weak in other words we couldn't
run with this story in the news section
cuz it ain't news so he ran with it in
the broader context of Yale climate at
the time to try and illuminate what was
going on in the seedy halls of Yale but
even how they phrased the accusation is
not true so they say the essay included
a previously unreported claim that
friends did this right and then they say
during the author's investigation they
learned that a classmate max tyre
witnessed the event that's not okay what
the story says that max tyre claims he
witnessed the event it does not say that
they had stories about an event and then
found a guy to corroborate that story
that would be double sourcing if they
just went to max
dier and he says hey you know what I saw
a thing that's not double sourced the
entire problem with the story is it's
not double sourced but if you actually
read those two sentences they make it
sound like it's double sourced they make
it sound like somebody claimed this
happened and so they went and found a
witness to it
that's not what the original New York
Times story says okay and that wasn't
the limit of the New York Times
stupidity over all of this all the news
that's fit to print over there the old
grey lady apparently going senile we got
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about something
important you can do you want to
preserve your memories you know outside
the auspices of the New York Times
trying to jog them perhaps you should go
and preserve the memories that you got
in your garage you know in that cabinet
in the back here house the ones the oven
looked at in a while you got tapes you
got old VHS is and you have film reels
from your parents and you've got old
photos that are degrading why not just
have all those digitized why not have
all that digitized put on a thumb drive
put on the DVD and then it's easy to
access you can use it if God forbid
something happens you can run out of the
house with it without having to schlep a
bunch of boxes to your car they don't
degrade right this is all great this is
what Legacy Box does and it is a
fantastic fantastic idea for a gift
there are lots of people who are using
legacy box for a lot of reason you're
saving all of your family films and
photos from degrading or being lost
forever maybe you don't have a VCR
anymore so you can't even watch the
tapes well now you can send your legacy
box filled with old home movies and
pictures and then legacy box does the
rest they professionally digitize your
moments onto a thumb drive digital
download or DVD
they've got easy-to-follow instructions
and safety bar codes included for every
single item over 450,000 families have
trusted legacy box including mine
there's never been a better time to
digitally preserve your memories visit
legacy box comm today to get started
plus for a limited time they are
offering my listeners an exclusive
discount just head on over to legacy box
comm slash Shapiro's to get 40% off your
first order again legacy box comm slash
up here is a 40 percent today get
started preserving your past at legacy
box comm slash apparel get 40% off your
first or a great company I know the
folks who run it who run it and founded
it and you're doing yourself and your
family a service go check them out at
legacy box.com slash Shapiro okay so as
I say the New York Times incompetence is
not limited to merely what they reported
in what they did and they then tweeted
out something about how it may have
seemed like harmless fun when Brett
Kavanaugh started waving his penis
around at people
and in turn and then they had to delete
it because who said that was harmless
fun has anyone ever said that term was
fun like really is that is that a common
thing that people call it harmless fun
well according to the New York Times the
opinions section like other parts of the
times has a process for writing and
editing social media copy in this case
the process was not followed properly
resulting in a tweet that fell well
below our standards the Department is
reviewing with everyone involved
including me what went wrong to
determine how we can avoid similar
mistakes well turns out there are now
allegations that the person who actually
wrote the tweet were the reporters in
that particular story so they wrote the
tweet and the New York Times tweeted it
out as though it was the opinion of the
New York Times itself I mean this is
just this is all a battery it is a
massive massive battery all of this led
president Trump to go off as he is want
to do see he was doing a rally in New
Mexico he's trying to turn New Mexico
red again and he brought up the
Cavanaugh stuff as well he should
because it is perfect evidence of just
how biased the media are and how
terrible they very often are at their
jobs listen I'm somebody who relies on
major mainstream media reporters
particularly in foreign reporting to
actually get the facts right you
undermine the credibility of your own
outlet when you do stuff like this
there's president from going hard after
the New York Times I just put out a
statement on social media that said I
don't think they'll do it but they
should for the good of the nation I call
for the resignation of everybody at the
New York Times involved in the
Cavanaugh's
and while you're at it the Russian
witch-hunt hoax which is just as phony a
story The Times is dead long live the
New York Times ok so president Trump
going hard after the time and doing so
with a reason Mitch McConnell who is not
exactly known for getting a fiery on the
Senate floor I mean the man has the
demeanor of a turtle and looks to match
here is Mitch McConnell yesterday
getting pretty upset I don't know if he
he has a broken arm or something he's
done something to his arm in this clip
maybe it was just from slamming his desk
out of frustration at the idiocy of the
media here is Mitch McConnell talking
about the Kavanagh rehash once again
over the last couple of days leading
Democrats have tried to grab on to yet
another poorly sourced thinly reported
unsubstantiated allegation against
justice Brett Kavanaugh but it would be
a mistake to dismiss this as a bad case
of sour grapes this is not just a
left-wing obsession with one man it's
part of a deliberate effort to attack
judicial independence when you were this
willing to launch unhinged personal
attacks you reveal a whole lot more
about your own radicalism than about the
men and women your target okay so here
is how the media have responded to this
okay he is right of course the fact is
the Democrats have no new evidence none
none zero zip zilch in fact as I say the
main revelation from the new book is
that Christine Blasi Ford's best friend
does not believe her and not only does
not believe her has now suggested openly
that she was being pressured by
Christine Blasi Ford and allies to go
after Brett Kavanaugh that's an
astonishing story that's an astonishing
story imagine that the same thing had
happened about Paula Jones in the 1990s
that there is somebody who Paula Jones
counted on as a witness to her encounter
with Bill Clinton and then that person
had come out and say not only do I not
believe Paula Jones Paula and her
friends in the Republican Party we're
calling me and pressuring me you think
that might've been front-page news but
here it's not front-page news it's
reported but grudgingly then late by the
New York Times here's how the media have
decided to cover all of this so is the
story the battery of the near attempts
no that's not the story the story
is according to the Washington Post in
action on Kavanagh allegations reignites
political rancor so you get this you get
this so another empty allegation is put
forward with no corroborating evidence
none that was the main topic of our show
yesterday that went viral okay there is
no corroborating evidence whatsoever
from anyone who is willing to go on the
record we don't know the names of any
witnesses to these events who say that
they were present the main quote-unquote
victims in these cases the alleged
victims do not specifically recall the
events even Tupper Ramirez who's now
being trotted out as the main witness to
a sexual assault she had to spend six
days talking with her lawyer and
refreshing her memory before she even
felt comfortable talking about this
whole thing and then you have Christine
Blasi Ford whose entire story is doubted
by her main witness Leland Kaiser and
the story isn't Democrats try to
reignite political fervor with empty
allegations no the story is you know the
Republicans didn't fully investigate
these empty allegations how would they
invest a real serious question how would
you suggest that they investigate an
allegation by a guy who provided
apparently no details in which the
alleged victim doesn't recall the event
how do you purport to go about
investigating that you know law
enforcement has resources those
resources are not endless they don't
spend every day tracking down every
allegation of misbehavior that is that
in which there is no support of the
evidence provided but here is the
reporting again great reporting over at
The Washington Post by Sungmin Kim in
action on Kavanagh allegations reignites
political rancor four days before Brett
Kavanaugh was confirmed to the Supreme
Court by the narrowest of margins
Senator Chris Coons sent a letter to the
FBI urging appropriate follow-up on new
information he believed was relevant to
sexual misconduct allegations made
against the nominee then apparently not
much happened not at the FBI which
assured Coons it had received the letter
but did not interview the person whom
the senator referred to the bureau not
in the office of then Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Charles Grassley
republican of iowa which was copied on
the letter that contained few in the way
of specifics by the way Grassley says
that they never really even received the
letter it is also important I love that
that they just sort of by the way it
contained very little in the way of
specifics maybe that's why the FBI
didn't spend its time and resources
investigating if you say I saw a bad
thing happy
what do you think FBI is gonna do with
that not among Democrats several of whom
had been unaware of the information
until the New York Times report this
weekend details a new alleged incident
involving Cavanaugh so weird Chris Coons
knew about this why didn't all the other
Democrats if he thought it was such a
serious allegation why was it Nancy
Pelosi yelling about it where were all
the other Democrats yelling about it
according to the Washington Post that
inaction made public in recent days
through new reports about Cavanaugh's
alleged misbehavior has renewed a bitter
debate about how his confirmation was
handled angering Democrats about a
process they felt was rushed and
animating Republicans who decried what
they viewed his attempts to assassinate
Kavanagh his character I love that the
idea here is that what's what led to
this outrage is a lack of investigation
by the FBI not a bunch of fresh non
corroborated allegations from the New
York Times that have been blown so far
out of proportion that the New York
Times wouldn't run this as a news story
because they didn't feel there was
enough Jews so in other words the New
York Times editorial board said this
isn't news enough for us to run in the
news section but the Washington Post and
New York Times editorial boards also say
the FBI should have expended full
resources investigating this nothing
bergeron allegation it's unreal and it's
obviously politically motivated just as
the original allegations against
Cavanaugh were by the Democrats now
plays before it I don't know why Blasi
Ford did what but maybe it happened
maybe it didn't I have no evidence one
way or the other neither do you that's
the point without evidence how the hell
are we supposed to judge if a thing is
true but what I do know is that the
Democrats with no evidence we're willing
to destroy the character of Brett
Kavanaugh they're willing to malign him
and lie about him and now they're doing
the same thing for political gain I'll
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about that credit card
debt you've been racking up now let's be
real it is very easy to fall into credit
card debt you're told that you just buy
for it now and you pay for it later and
the problem is you get behind on those
credit card bills and they really start
racking up the interest charges well now
you have a solution that is Lending Club
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself and
how much you want to borrow pick the
terms that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank accounts in as
little as a few days Lending Club is the
number
one peer-to-peer lending platform with
over 35 billion dollars in loans issued
it's really easy to get into debt
some people just overspend some people
do it by accident because they just
needed to use a credit card to get by on
their bills but there's no reason you
should be living with those enormous up
charges from the credit card companies
instead go consolidate your debt over at
Lending Club comm / Bend you can check
your rate in minutes you can borrow up
to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / Ben Lending
Club comm / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
that is Lending Club com / Ben go check
them out right now so as I say the
media's angle on this is the FBI is bad
so just to get this straight it's not
that the New York Times is bad for
printing a baseless allegation or for
editing that baseless allegations to
make it seem like it had more of a basis
or for not bold-faced reporting on
kristinb lazy Ford's close friend
undercutting her entire allegation now
the problem here is the FBI so The
Washington Post editorial board has a
piece today titled the FBI investigation
into Brett Kavanaugh turned out to be
more of a sham than it seemed and this
was the word of the day yesterday was
sham he's taught in every Democratic
tweet a sham investigation sham this
almost as though everybody's
talking to each other and using exactly
the same verbiage weird weird
so the Washington Post editorial board
says in September 2018 as the battle
over the confirmation of Brett Kavanaugh
to the Supreme Court rage then Senator
Jeff Flake of Arizona and Chris Coons of
Delaware struck a deal mr. flake would
delay confirming Kavanaugh until the FBI
completed an investigation into credible
allegations of sexual misconduct but the
investigation couldn't be open and
open-ended her last ages despite these
caveats both senators insisted the
inquiry must be conducted in good faith
GOP senators who subsequently voted to
confirm mr. Kavanagh praised the
resulting investigation for being
thorough
now comes additional evidence that the
investigation was in fact far from
thorough and more of a sham than it
seemed at the time reasonable
investigative steps were not pursued on
the gumshoes over at the Washington Post
they know I know those gumshoes as FBI
experts again I said at the time that
that the foolishness of Jeff Flake
caving to the Democrats and pretending
as though any FBI investigation would
please them is insane the FBI does not
have unlimited resources beyond that it
is not the FBI's job to track down
every unverified allegation made about a
human there were literally thousands of
allegations that came in all of them I
mean I'm talking about like the crazy
letters not one has been substantiated
not one by the you think the press
haven't spent time trying to
substantiate this stuff if it was that
easy like what was the FBI gonna do
truly but the media have not already
done or have done now and still the
media can't come up with anything so
show me the evidence that the FBI missed
the thing what's the thing they missed
what's the crucial area they missed here
according to the Washington Post in an
article adapted from their forthcoming
book on the Kavanagh controversy to New
York Times reporters revealed that the
FBI interviewed practically no one
regarding them one of the allegations
against mr. Cavanaugh in which one of
his Yale classmates Deborah Ramirez said
Kavanaugh drunkenly exposed himself to
her during a Senate testimony Kavanagh
said if the incident miss Ramirez
describes had occurred it would have
been the talk of campus our reporting
suggested that it was the reporters
wrote they found that federal agents
interviewed none of the two dozen people
who miss Ramirez said could bolster her
story and ignored in the analogous of a
second episode okay the second episode
is the one that we are talking about as
far as the as far as the general
allegation that there that she had two
dozen witnesses or whatever weird
because she provided exactly those
witnesses to these New York Times
reporters and they could come up with no
one who actually verified her story in
fact she herself couldn't verify her
story because she said that she had to
sit around for a week trying to figure
out if it was Brett Kavanaugh but
according to the Washington Post this
investigative shot eNOS was apparently
the fault not of the FBI but of
Republicans looking for cover at first
they limited the FBI questioning to only
four people about two separate
allegations agents eventually got an
expansion they contacted ten people but
not an extension of their deadline as
though the deadline actually mattered
here if they could have extended the
deadline for months
bottom line is that the media are
grasping for any straw with which to
club the DOJ and it's a Club Trump and a
club Kavanagh and it doesn't matter that
this allegation fell apart upon arrival
it was DOA and it doesn't matter they're
treating it as though it is inanimate
corpse wheeling that sucker around like
weekend at Bernie's gonna pretend
there's an actual story it inked in it
and all this is part of a broader trend
which is the supposed corruption inside
the Trump administration over at the DOJ
and
like really really weak stuff in a
second we'll get to a little bit more on
this first you know what I do when I
want to take a break from the political
Maelstrom
well I head on over to the sports page
because I love love sports which is why
I am excited to share with you a new
daily sports podcast from wandering and
the athletic you're gonna want to listen
to it's called the lead every weekday
morning the lead will bring you one big
story from the Athletics all-star team
of local and national sports reporters
some stories will be a fresh take on a
major news event other episodes will
feature an in-depth look into what's
been happening off the field from the
story of how truly awful call in last
year's NFL playoffs enraged the entire
city of New Orleans
so we in-depth interviews on mental
health and sports the lead is your daily
lens into the biggest stories of the day
it's hosted by by a couple of great
sports writers --kavitha davidson and
anders kalto who will take you close to
the story from comprehensive reporting
fascinating clips exclusive interviews
you won't hear anywhere else I love
staying up to speed on sports and so
I've made this a regular part of my diet
go subscribe to the lead on Apple
podcast or wherever you are listening to
this right now again if you love sports
and you need a break from the craziness
of the day you're gonna want to go check
out the lead on Apple podcasts from
wandering it is fantastic okay in just a
second we're gonna get to New York
prosecutors honing in on president
Trump's tax returns and we'll get to
Elizabeth Warren threatening to violate
the Constitution every which way from
Sunday first you have to go over to
Daley wire.com and subscribe when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
get the rest of our you get the rest of
Andrew Klavan show live at Matt Walsh's
show live and Michael Moses terrible
show live you got all of those wonderful
things also when you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessel so the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler
filling up nearly daily and you get the
same sort of access the Media Matters
has to this show you know where they
watch the show and then clip out of
context a lot of things from the show
and put them up you can do the same
exact thing except not be an evil piece
of garbage like the people at Media
Matters go check us out right now over
at Daily wire calm again for 99 bucks a
year you're helping keep us on the air
you're helping us bring you the material
that you love and that you need we
really appreciate it we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the Democratic candidates of course
making hay out of this Cavanaugh thing
even though there's no hay to make
Kamala Harris who is the most rehearsed
I mean she people have compared
Elizabeth Warren to Hillary Clinton
Connell Harris is much more similar to
Hillary Clinton than Elizabeth Lorna's
so Elizabeth Warren is a lot more shrewd
she doesn't appear quite as calculated
as Kamala Harris Kamala Harris is
rehearse in every way shape or form here
she was on MSNBC last night with Rachel
Maddow and just really wildly
entertaining stuff and here's come all
the hair sex planing now when it came to
the cabinet hearing men were coming up
to her on the street in public places
crying to which I'm gonna say that's a
bunch of crap here's Komal Harris I mean
listen after the initial hearings that
happened a year ago the number of women
and men who approached me in you know
public places and cried about what this
meant to them because there is so much
about this issue and one of the worst
things that happens is that when we are
not willing to believe the victim and
take them seriously okay if we're gonna
get back into this routine believe I'll
believe all women the this whole
nonsense that you push before have up
believe most women help believe women
and and how about not by percentage how
about believe allegations that have
substantiation to back them up hell of
that how about like corroborated details
she was a prosecutor for God's sake and
do I really believe that men were coming
up to Kamala Harris on the street
wrapping their arms around her and
sobbing on her shoulder about Brett
Kavanaugh no no I'm sorry I don't
believe that the good news for common
law Harris is she's receiving a bit of a
renaissance in the media there's a big
article in The Washington Post yesterday
about Kamala Harris going to Howard
University there's another big article
in The New York Times about Kamala
Harris they're trying to sort of
revitalize her campaign because they're
starting to realize that Elizabeth
Warren has no support in the black
community and that Kamala Harris may
have more support in the black community
if she gets better media coverage
they're trying to revive if I her the
the most Awkward attempt at revivifying
her dying candidacy I mean she was it
like 16% two months ago she's now at
five or six percent this happened on
Jimmy Fallon I don't know why Jimmy
Fallon continues to do this but he does
this
slow jamming the news with particular
Democratic candidates and it's so
awkward and so terrible and so telling
here's Jimmy Fallon slow jamming the
news with Kamala Harris if you call this
comedy or entertainment man let me
recommend that you actually go view some
actual comedy que Haga t but I gotta ask
lately this country has been so divided
sleeping on opposite sides of the bed
why do you think we can't all just come
together well it's my opinion that we
need a president who fights for the best
of who we are and over the past three
years Donald Trump has done the exact
opposite hold up so what you're trying
to say is that Trump's the bad guy duh
so much humor so much comedy Inc I can't
imagine my Jimmy Fallon is falling apart
in the ratings
Kamala Harris wildly entertaining good
good stuff there from the 2020
Democratic candidates now the fact is
that she is not part of this race at
this point at all right the main factors
in this race are Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren held this massive rally in New
York yesterday her campaign said 20,000
people showed up the cop said something
like 5,000 people showed up whatever it
is she is generating enthusiasm maybe
it's a little bit astroturf but she's
generating enthusiasm she was speaking
yesterday in New York City and she
explained how basically she is just
going to start ignoring this thing
called the Constitution she suggested
that she's gonna use her executive
authority as president of the United
States to fix the so-called pay gap
between men and women this coming from a
millionaire woman who's paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars to teach property
at Harvard Law School for decades
here she is explaining that women are
highly victimized she should become
president administration I will use my
executive authority to start closing the
pay gap
between women of color and everyone else
we must recognize the systemic
discrimination that infects our economy
and we must work actively and
deliberately to root it out and set this
country on a better path my god she's
boring I mean that is intensely boring
stuff and false stuff by the way
whenever she talks about the pay gap she
uses the debunked statistics basically
aggregating the average wage of various
groups against the average wage of other
various groups without concern with
number of hours worth or the kind of job
held or educational level or time in the
workforce or time away from the
workforce or any of that sort of stuff
you can't use your executive authority
to fix the pay gap you're gonna have to
explain how you're going to do that but
I love that people cheer for this sort
of stuff because people have come to
believe on both the right and the left
and it's really irritating that the
president is a magical magical personage
and if the president is just the right
person then they can wave their magic
wand and boom all of your problems just
disappear well she pledged and other
problems she would make disappear she
said she was gonna fight corruption did
Elizabeth Warren which is always amusing
since Democrats are very much in the
pocket of a bunch of different political
interests including particular unions
Elizabeth Warren yesterday suggested
that she was basically going to run
roughshod over the First Amendment so
it's not just that she's gonna run
roughshod over the checks and balances
of power she's also gonna run roughshod
over the First Amendment
the right of every person in this
country to petition their government
does not protect a multi-billion dollar
influence industry whose sole purpose is
to undermine democracy and tilt every
decision in favor of those who can pay
hey now do unions Elizabeth Warren now
do unions like it's always fascinating
to watch is the exact same people who
are celebrating Walmart for injecting
itself into the second amendment debate
and celebrating like Zara's and
forever21 for having comments about
abortion if those same exact people who
are looking to corporations to be on
moral leaders like those corporations
have no rights they have no rights ok
well if the corporations are not people
then you're gonna have to explain to me
why you should tax a corporation it's
not a person so why should you be able
to tax a corporation is just a legal
entity after all why are you able to
prosecute corporations why are you able
to bring them to court and sue them so
they're treated as people in every way
under the law except for if you and I
get together form an LLC and decide that
we want to spend some money on a bond an
issue ad in Virginia then and then it's
very bad then isn't then it's corporate
influencing unless we're Union if we
form a union then Elizabeth Warren is
totally fine with it ok this is Jenna is
particularly radical but Elizabeth
Warren is is stealing the Bernie base
and it's working out well for her
meanwhile president from facing a couple
of new obstacles today according to the
Associated Press New York City
prosecutors have now subpoenaed
president Trump's tax returns a person
familiar with the matter told the AP on
Monday now I've long suspected that the
reason that President Trump doesn't want
his tax returns revealed is because
they're going to reveal that he is not
as wealthy as he says he is which again
I'm not sure why he cares at this point
he should just be like whatever man I'm
only worth a billion dollars or half a
billion dollars as opposed to ten
billion dollars like does he really
believe anybody cares about that truly
doesn't make a few for a few late-night
jokes and everybody would go yeah he's
way better than I am
so whatever nonetheless he is he's now
fighting a battle with the Manhattan
district attorney's office at Cyrus
Vance their office recently sent a
subpoena to president Trump's accounting
firm seeking the last eight years of
state and federal tax returns for Trump
and his company the Trump Organization
the person said this person who talked
to the AP was not authorized
speak publicly about the matter and
spoke on the condition of anonymity
asked about the subpoena as he left the
White House on Monday Trump said I don't
know anything about it a lawyer for the
Trump Organization Mark mikaze said he's
evaluating the situation and will
respond as appropriate Vance is a
Democrat of course he subpoenaed the
Trump Organization last month for
records related to payments that Trump's
former lawyer Michael Cohen helped to
arrange to a porn actress who claimed
she had an affair with Trump his office
is also pursuing a state mortgage fraud
case against former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort now maybe there's
crime there maybe there's not you do get
the feeling that Cyrus Vance is
basically sitting there with a target
list and then trying to dig up crime on
the particular target list now if he
digs up crime so be it
what the chips fall where they may crime
is crime and should be punished
accordingly but again there's something
disquieting about prosecutors sitting
there and using their influence in order
to target particularly political enemies
Trump has already been fighting efforts
by several Democratic like congressional
committees to obtain his tax returns in
other records that could give them a
window into his finances of course Trump
and his kids filed a lawsuit in April
seeking to block House committees from
getting records that his longtime
Leonard H bank has said includes tax
returns saying that this is not relevant
to any investigation Trump happens to be
right about that he is right but with
that said Democrats are not going to let
up in any of this it is pretty amazing
that the members of the New York Bar who
are in charge of law enforcement have
openly said that they're targeting Trump
a New York Attorney General Letitia
James is now investigating whether Trump
exaggerated his wealth to obtain loans
again
she said upon taking office that Trump
was basically in her crosshairs which is
pretty disturbing whether you're right
or left the idea of a prosecutor sitting
there and being like I don't like this
guy I'm gonna find something needed that
is troubling typically prosecutors find
crime and then prosecuted they don't
find people and then try to find crimes
that they committed as an excuse for
prosecution okay so that is one problem
on Trump's hands the other problem on
Trump's hands is that it is very rare
that a first-term president does not
experience some sort of foreign policy
crisis and we could be looking at that
foreign policy crisis over in Iran it
looks as though the foreign policy
crisis with China may be abating just a
little bit it doesn't mean a long-term
trade deal with China is on the table
nor really should it be until they stop
stealing our
electril property but it seems like the
tensions are abating just enough that
we're not gonna have a full-scale trade
war but as that happens tensions are
ramping up in the Middle East where Iran
is doing its damnedest in order to
pressure the Europeans to make
concessions to it run Monday president
from stopped short of directly blaming
Iran for a major attack on Saudi oil
installations a laying at least for a
moment fears of a military conflict
between the United States and Iran
president Trump obviously does not want
to go to war with Iran his
administration does not want to go to
war with Iran even John Bolton did not
desperately want to go to war with Iran
contrary to popular opinion John Bolton
wanted to respond to fire if fire were
to happen but I am not aware that John
Bolton was advocating for heavy air
strikes on Central Iranian military
targets the only airstrikes I think he
was in favor of was in response to ships
being bombed in the Straits of Hormuz
and he was suggesting that certain naval
targets in the Iranian Navy be hit
officials in Washington in Riyadh spent
the day analyzing satellite photos and
other intelligence they said indicated
that Iranian weapons were used in the
assault on Saudi Aramco facilities but
they presented no new information that
would conclusively show that Iran
directed or launch the attack Saudi
officials said it led to a 50% reduction
in oil production u.s. officials did
reject claims by Houthi rebels in Yemen
that they launched the strike they said
it was too sophisticated and powerful
for that but Trump is for the moment
withholding withholding his his judgment
on whether in fact it was Iran from said
on Monday I'm not looking to get into
new conflict but sometimes you have to
asked what message he wanted to send to
a Ron Trump said I think I'll have a
stronger message or maybe no message at
all when we get the final results of
what we're looking at there's no rush so
Trump is not rushing to go to war here
there seems to be a contingent of the
Republican Party that believes that he
is and that I find weird I've yet to see
the evidence that Trump is desperate to
enmesh us in a serious foreign war tulsi
gabbard Democratic presidential
candidate who has not met any of the
thresholds for remaining in the debate
she's an isolationist on foreign policy
of course very close with Bashar Assad
in Syria and has toured over there and
has praised him in any case she went
after Trump suggesting that Trump was
prostituting the United States out at
the behest of the Saudis yesterday
president Trump offered to place our
military my brothers and sisters in
uniform
under the command of Prince Mohammed bin
Salman the dictator of the Islamist
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia you're offering
our military assets to the dictator of
Saudi Arabia to use as he sees fit is a
betrayal of my brothers and sisters in
uniform who are ready to give our lives
for our country
not for the Islamist dictator of Saudi
Arabia my fellow service members and I
we are not your prostitutes you are not
our pimp okay I am not aware I am not
aware anywhere here that Trump offered
to put our soldiers under the command of
Mohammed bin Salman right no one would
be in favor of that including President
Trump that's that's in the same
contention we can see that Trump is not
interested in going to war here the
truth is that the only solution may be
to just muddle through and this is the
underrated solution in American foreign
policy everybody always wants a final
answer to Syria's foreign policy
questions how can we make it so that
terrorists are never a threat again the
answer is you can't how can you make it
so that Iran doesn't threaten the region
well maybe you can't maybe you have to
just contain them maybe every day that
there's not a full-scale war is a good
day maybe every day that Iran is not
multiplying its terrorist influence is a
good day maybe every day that Iran goes
without the funds necessary to spread
its cancerous tentacles throughout the
Middle East is a good day maybe that
maybe foreign policy is really about
just maintaining I know that's not
romantic and it's not sexy but maybe
that's really what foreign policy
generally is and then you wait for
opportunities to make a major push and
those opportunities are rare and maybe
that opportunity is not what is
happening right now I think Trump is
actually demonstrating a fair bit of
common sense here that I think is well
well worth it here's Trump yesterday
explaining listen I haven't promised the
Saudis that we're going to protect them
and that at the same time he's saying
well I'm not letting the Iranians know
that we won't protect them because then
that would obviously lead the Iranians
to get more aggressive and that's not
wrong no I haven't no I have and I
haven't promised the Saudis that we have
to sit down with the Saudis and work
something out and the Saudis want very
much for us to protect them but I say
well we have to work that was an attack
on Saudi Arabia
and that wasn't an attack on us so now
they're under attack and we will work
something out with them but they also
know that you know I'm not looking to
get into new conflict but sometimes you
have to as a president Trump was talking
with the Pentagon the Pentagon is urging
him not to get into a new conflict and a
message posted on Twitter on Twitter
Mark Esper who's the defense secretary
he he said that the United States
military and other government agencies
will quote working with our partners to
address this unprecedented attack and
defend the international rules-based
order that is being undermined by Iran
so there is this delicate dance that is
being played one of the things that has
to happen obviously is the United States
should work to strengthen Saudis
capacity to defend itself against
Iranian incursions otherwise it does put
the US on the hook every time we're on
every time
Saudi Arabia is in threat of invasion
right me that's how he ended up in the
first Gulf War the United States should
be working with foreign nations to flag
their vessels the United States should
be providing escorts to foreign boats in
the Straits of Hormuz a garage should
know that we're not looking for all-out
war but if you fire on an international
and flag vessel you will be fired upon
and if you attempt to send drones into
Saudi Arabia the Saudis should have the
capacity to shoot down those drones and
to retaliate in like fashion against
Iranian military targets that's a
deterrence is an aspect of foreign
policy there seems to be this weird
binary view of American foreign policy
where if the United States threatens
force that that ends up meaning that we
use force we threaten force like all the
time in American foreign policy and that
is what is called deterrence the vast
majority of cases deterrence is enough
we have the most powerful military on
planet earth you know who doesn't want
war more than the United States Iran
because if Iran were to actually go to
full-scale war with the United States
you know who ends up dead the mullahs
okay that is not a war that the Iranians
want to fight now does that mean that
the United States should want to fight
that war of course not of course not I
mean we have too many people in the
region our bases are not sufficiently
protected we we are stretched militarily
because of the Obama year cuts but with
that said foreign policy is a delicate
balance of the threat the credible
threat of aggression combined with a
desire for defusing situations and I
think
that President Trump has not done a bad
job on this front at all and I think he
continues to do a good job in around we
need to keep the pressure up we need to
strengthen Saudi Arabia's ability to
defend itself from these sorts of
incursions but we shouldn't be looking
to go to all-out war and I think frankly
that is where President Trump is at this
point okay time for some things I like
and then time for some things that I
hate so things that I like today there
is a phenomenal series on Netflix a
really first-rate series on Netflix
starring Sacha Baron Cohen who as it
turns out can act a not just a comedic
actor actually a good like actor actor
and the series is called the spy he
plays a spy named Ellie Cohen Ellie
Cohen was one of the most famous spies
in Israeli history he actually rose to
become effectively the deputy defense
minister of Syria it's an amazing story
he infiltrated the government of Syria
in the 1960s and became so friendly with
everybody that they elevated him to one
of the top government positions he was
special defense adviser to the President
of Syria in the middle of the Israeli
Syrian conflict and his work was
responsible for saving innumerable
Israeli lives it's it's a touching story
it's a tragic story it's it's it's
really really well done Gideon raff was
the guy behind the original Israeli
version of homeland created the series
and Baron Cohen does a terrific job with
it here's a little bit of the preview do
you consider yourself a patriot
I love this country with all my mind
welcome to city if your country needed
you to lie to your friends your family
your life would you do it I will be
Empire working for the government if
your country asks you to risk your life
would you do it this is the opportunity
for me to give you the life that I
promised you nothing
my name my name is coming I mean a bit
shake it really is terrific
I mean first freight well produced
beautiful beautiful looking tragic its I
can't speak highly enough for the series
it really is great go check out this buy
one of the things that's great about
this pie is that it does make clear the
stakes in the Middle East so today is
Israel's election here's the reality of
Israel's election it does not matter who
the Prime Minister of Israel is the
defense policy will be nearly precisely
the same okay the left in the United
States and internationally would like to
pretend that with Netanyahu not in power
suddenly Israel is going to cut some
sort of deal with terrorists it ain't
happening the left in Israel no longer
exists
Kovalev on which is the the centrist
party that is a center-right party if it
were not for the fact that Netanyahu
because he is a power broker in Israeli
politics and a power player and very
Machiavellian had basically ousted a lot
of former leaders inside his own Likud
Party the fact is that the Likud
coalition would be like 90 seats not 60
so we'll see how the elections shake out
tonight but this does raise the question
of continued anti-semitism because this
movie does show there's one fantastic
scene in which Elly Cohen is at the
Syrian border and in a Syrian
high-ranking military officers
explaining that killing civilians is
totally worthwhile and necessary because
each civilian that is killed in Israel
is killing a future soldier or a current
soldier in there looking like shooting
farmers it's it's a pretty telling
moment the fact is that that is the
anti-semitism that Israel does face in
the Middle East they have always faced
that in the Middle East it's not going
to abate anytime soon the Israeli
government knows it the sensor knows it
the right knows that the Israeli people
know it okay time for a quick thing that
I hate
so speaking of the continued prevalence
of anti-semitism and the willingness to
abide it on the left the women's March
has gotten rid of some of its leaders so
they finally got rid of Linda Sarsour
she is out was Bob Lance was Tamika
Mallory SAR sewer of course is a rabid
anti-semite Tameka Mallory's a person
who is paid homage to Louis Farrakhan
repeatedly well now they've been
replaced isn't that exciting and they've
been replaced by a bunch of people who
are basically just as terrible there's
one named Zara Balu okay and turns out
that Zara Balu is just a civil rights
lawyer and now a new head of the women's
March she has some opinions on the Jews
and it's not great she's tweeted in
favor of of Hezbollah and Hamas
she's tweeted in favor she accused the
FBI of recruiting mentally ill young
people for Isis okay she she suggested
that that Hamas is superior to what she
calls apartheid Israel
she says Israel is an apartheid racist
state which engages in terrorism against
Palestinians just in case the Zionists
didn't hear me so they replaced some
anti-semites with other anti-semites
which is really exciting and solid stuff
well done everybody
she actually tweeted out in 2014 blaming
Hamas for firing rockets and apartheid
Israel is like blaming a woman for
punching her rapist Hamas was demócratas
democratically elected to govern
Palestine so she's an actual terrorist
supporter the women's March replaced
some some anti-semites with other
anti-semites also she'll be joined in
the leadership of the women's March by a
woman named Samia I said who apparently
also tweeted the more appropriate
question to ask in the context of this
conversation is do you believe in how
Israel exists now I will tell you know
to this day Israel has never declared
its borders and continues to occupy
lands and deny Palestinians human rights
so just wonderful job everybody you've
done you've done fantastic work there
over at the women's March it's just
weird how this coincidence keeps
happening just keeps happening over and
over but don't worry anti-semitism is
dead it doesn't exist and obviously
Israel needs to elect someone who's
going to make a deal with Hamas at the
behest of Ilhan Omar just so long
listen Ilhan Omar says as long as
Netanyahu is not existent if he stops
existing things will be better the world
may be in for a rude awakening because
whether Netanyahu is re-elected in which
case everybody freaks out or whether
Netanyahu has not reelect 'add and the
new government does exactly what the old
government did they're about to find out
the Israeli public is not willing to go
quietly into that good night at the
behest of the International Left and
their terrorist allies in Hamas and
Hezbollah alrighty we'll be back here
tomorrow with the results of the Israeli
election among other pieces of news i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you